[Music]
it's nice host so one of the classic
things to do in slow motion
yeah it's to do a water balloon full of
what a popin looks cool yeah we've done
plenty of that over the years I thought
that was a pretty small balloon though
it was that was actually a balloon only
this big stretched out about that big
when it was fully yeah get rid of that
and use this so I see how we get on yeah
oh yeah all right let's move all the
cameras back
don't you dare call this what are you
gonna mean for surprise when this pops
look I know how much you hate water
you see they would yeah all right yeah
let's pull it up dirty yeah it took all
my way
Oh
[Music]
this is what made you go there it's
closed for slightly more desperate
measures I do not think this is a good
idea at all
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who are you I'm George you know what are
you to me I'm your brother right tree
jump on this mess of the air that's
there I'm just gonna do this
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
Wow this made a bit of a flush again
[Music]